i
feel like we're at the oscars like this
is the most amazing feeling
[Music]
you're shouting your name out there i
know it's just like and i'm not even on
the show the series co-creator and ep
left her two kids at home but their
godfather her former the office co-star
ex bj novak was on mindy's mind after
admitting she's not bothered by rumors
he's actually the children's father how
special is it to have bj has another
support system for your kid he's very
good with children he literally wrote a
best-selling book called the book of no
pictures for a kid so he's it comes very
innately to him she's a great godfather
it's believable that we're together
right oh oh oh everyone always asks like
what's the best part of working with
mindy the best part is that i'm working
with with the best she is the best never
have i ever follows an indian american
teen navigating high school after the
death of her dad a john mcenroe super
fan last night the tennis phenom
revealed how mindy got him to sign on i
was at a vanity fair oscar party we were
sort of walking by each other mindy says
oh my god i have this idea to do a show
now normally that never comes to
fruition but somehow it did and here we
are and unbelievable so when you get the
call that they want you to be the voice
of a 17 year old indian girl your
reaction is uh you cannot be serious
the hottest guy at sherman oaks high and
i think it's worked